en este vídeo queremos encontrar la
derivada de esta gtx de al principio
parece intimidante tiene por aquí el
seno de x por acá al coseno de x y por
acá esta expresión loquísima de pi entre
la raíz cúbica de x todo esto elevado al
cuadrado así que efectivamente tal vez
parezca un poco intimidante al principio
pero como veremos en este vídeo podemos
encontrar la derivada con las
herramientas que ya tenemos utilizaremos
las propiedades de las derivadas que
conocemos la regla de la potencia que
nos dice que la derivada con respecto a
x de x elevado a la potencia n es igual
a n que multiplica a x elevado a la
potencia n 1 ya la hemos visto en muchas
ocasiones también usaremos el
conocimiento de que la derivada con
respecto a x del coseno dx es igual
- de equis y al revés la derivada con
respecto a x del seno de x es igual al
coseno de x
con esto ya podemos derivar esta
expresión es decir encontrar que prima
de x así que pausa el vídeo e intenta
resolverlo por tu cuenta
ya que sabemos cuál es la derivada del
seno de x y del coseno de x
probablemente la parte más intimidante
es la expresión que tenemos acá pero
podemos reescribir la o simplificar la
un poco de tal forma que nos resulte más
familiar así que hagámoslo en este lado
tenemos a pin entre la raíz cúbica de x
todo esto al cuadrado y esto es lo mismo
que pi al cuadrado entre la raíz cúbica
de x también al cuadrado solamente
estamos aplicando las propiedades de los
exponentes así que esto es lo mismo que
tomar x a la un tercio y elevarlo al
cuadrado así que esto será lo mismo que
bueno y cuadrada no quiero saltarme
pasos porque este es un repaso de las
propiedades de los exponentes entre x
elevado a la un tercio y esto elevado al
cuadrado lo que es igual a pico
/ x elevado a la dos tercios lo que es
igual a cuadrada por x elevada a la
menos dos tercios
así que escrita de esta forma ahora si
podemos pensar hoy en ahora si tenemos
una idea de cómo podemos aplicar aquí la
regla de la potencia
así que toda esta expresión complicada
es simplemente pi cuadrada por equis
elevada a la menos dos tercios es más
déjeme borrar todo esto para tener
espacio entonces podemos reescribir esto
como pi cuadrada por equis elevada a la
menos dos tercios
así que ahora tomemos la derivada de
cada uno de los pedazos de esta
expresión queremos encontrar que prima
tx entonces que prima es igual a
utilicemos el operador derivada de ambos
lados vamos a aplicar el operador
derivada al lado izquierdo y también
vamos a aplicárselo a esto
a esto y también a esto
entonces esta derivada es lo mismo que 7
por la derivada del seno de x lo que es
igual a 7 por el coseno de x esta otra
derivada es menos porque estamos
restando y sacamos la constante que está
multiplicando la expresión entonces nos
queda menos 3 por la derivada del coseno
de x que es menos seno de x
finalmente en esta parte en amarillo
apliquemos la regla de la potencia y no
olvidemos este signo negativo vamos a
escribirlo después multiplicaremos el
exponente menos dos tercios por el
coeficiente tal vez pueda parecer
confusa de nuevo la idea de pi cuadrada
pero es sólo un número
entonces esto será menos que multiplica
a menos dos tercios por pi cuadrada por
equis elevado a la menos dos tercios
menos uno y esto a que será igual bueno
nos quedará que prima de x es igual a 7
veces el coseno de x después tenemos
menos 3 por el menos seno de x eso es lo
mismo que más tres veces el seno de x
después tenemos menos por menos lo que
nos dará positivo entonces pondremos más
y nos queda 2 y cuadrada entre 3 esa es
esta parte de aquí por x elevado a la
bueno menos dos tercios menos uno
podemos pensarlo como menos un entero y
dos tercios o como menos cinco tercios x
elevado a la menos 5 tercios y listo
hemos acabado fuimos capaces de abordar
esta expresión que se veía un poco
peliaguda pero logramos obtener su
derivada utilizando la regla de la
potencia y lo que ya sabemos de las
derivadas del seno y cosenos de x